We have a number of webinars going on
please check back for other webinars
that might be of interest to you.
finally the materials the powerpoint i'm
going to be showing you are going to be
available.
there's a link at the very bottom of the
screen where you can get those materials
as well as any answers to questions that
we don't have time to get to today but
if you've asked questions will certainly
try and answer those and put those up
with the materials later.
alright so i'm going to go ahead and get
started. this should be about a 10-15
minute presentations today and then we
can go from there.
so we have some changes that are coming
up with the sequence databases and this
is a first webinar. we have a few other
announcements that have come out about
this but we're starting to try to do
some outreach about these changes so
that you have time to adjust to what's
going to be happening.
so the first thing i'll try and talk
about is what's changing
what's going on and the short answer to
that question is that we're phasing out a
kind of identifier called a GI number,
and i'll talk more about what those are
a couple minutes.
that's the next topic what they are a
little bit of a review of what kind of
identifiers that we use for the sequence
databases and why those changes are
happening and when they will happen. and
then the fourth topic
perhaps more interesting one, what's
going to break. if you have a piece of
software or service
what will break as a result of these
changes, won't break and we'll talk
briefly about that as well as some
additional service changes that we
anticipate that will be coming up in the
next weeks and months that are related
to these changes to
GI numbers. so what is changing? so we are
beginning to phase out the usage of the
GI number which has been a sequence
identifier used in the sequence databases
for many many years.
the one thing to remember about this is
that existing GI numbers, records that
already have a GI number,
those GI numbers will remain
indefinitely alright so we're not
deleting GI numbers from data, they will
be able to be used for retreaving those
sequences that have them already but the
real issue is that ncbi will not be
assigning GI numbers to all new
sequences that are being submitted. and
over time it will
eventually happen that we will not
assign GI numbers at all anymore. that's
going to be a gradual process and only
will affect new sequences.
what's happening soon in September is
that we will no longer show GI numbers
on flat file record views and fasta
record views by default. so those GI
numbers simply will not be present in
those data formats. the GI numbers will
still be present in the data record but
will not be visible in the flat file and
fasta formats. in march of 2017
you will not be able to see flat file or
fasta formats with GI numbers at
all.
so beginning in September 2016 they will
not be by default but you will still be
able to get these records with GI
numbers in them.
I will have more about that as we go
along but coming in March 2017 you won't
be able to see the GI numbers at all.
so you have about seven months of leeway
to prepare yourself for the fact that
you will no longer be able to get the GI
numbers out of flat files or fasta. so
I want to take on a brief moment to show
you the original announcement that came
out about this in March of this year.
there's a link to it here. i'm going to just switch over to a web browser
to the article itself.
this article is on the NCBI news page
it's the feature article on the NCBI news
site.
It's just www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/news.
you can see it there. i'm not going to
read through the whole article but i do
want to show you in the article there's
a couple of examples that kind of make
the point.
so this is part of a bit of a typical
nucleotide record in the nuccore
database.
what you'll see is the two identifiers
that you see now, the GI number and the
accession number. and you also see these
for the protein product in the feature
table down here, the accession number for
the protein and the GI number for the
protein.
what will be happening is that those GI
numbers simply will be gone, right, they
will not be shown in the records. you'll
simply see the accession
00:04:22,370 --> 00:04:26,900
for the protein id,
there will not be a GI number present. a
similar
thing will happen for the protein
records. again right now in a protein
record you'll see the accession number
and the GI in the same line. in the
future
the GI number will not be there.
similarly in fasta formatted records
currently, the def line of the fasta
or the title line of the fasta has a
seq ID identifier at the beginning which
starts with the gi and then a pipe and
then the GI number and then a pipe and
then a little code for the source
database, for example genbank in this
case, a pipe and then the accession. what will
happen in the future is that you'll
simply have the accession there and
nothing else.
so the g is gone, the pipes are gone. it's
much simpler, much more easy to parse but
the gi's are'nt present. so that's what
you're getting ready for, right, is
flat files and fasta records that don't
have the gi numbers present.
I'm going to go back to the slides here
and talk a little bit about what gi's are.
so just to review what gi's are and why
we've used them. so gi's are integers.
they point to a particular version of a
sequence record and you'll find them in
a variety of databases. so principally
in Entrez nuccore, nucEST, nucGSS, protein
and popset. all have records that are
identified with GI numbers.
this of course includes the genbank
database in its entirety and the RefSeq
database in its entirety. all of those
records also assign GI numbers and any
of those records on the web have a
report called a revision history which
I'm showing here. and revision history's
basically let you look at the history of
the versions of a particular record. this
record has an accession DQ656054,
but as you see here its had two GI
numbers in its history. because if a
sequence record changes the sequence
data, the sequence data itself is updated,
they're updated and the GI number will
shift.
so what's happened with this record it
came in 2006,
there was one update but the GI number
didn't change, that's because the update
wasn't to the sequence.
it could have been to the author lists,
it could have been to an added
publication, it could have been an
editorial change or to new annotation,
but the sequence itself didn't change.
But the sequence did change in august of
two thousand seven. when that changes the
GI is updated to a new number and the
version of the accession is also
incremented.
so now we have DQ656054.2, the second
version, as opposed to DQ656054.1.
so you can view this history for any
record in any of these databases
just go to the upper left and you can
pull down the menu and get to revision
history report.
so the point about accessions vs gi's is
that accessions point to a particular
version of a record, if you include the
version suffix, and the GI points to that
same record. So a given record, a
given version of a record, has always had
two identifiers, the GI number and the
accession.version. so the DQ656054.1
points to that particular GI number.
the updated record DQ656054.2 points to a different GI.
let's say that in the future that record
is updated again.
what would happen, could we predict what
would happen? From the accession number,
yes, we can predict because it will be
the same accession but it will be .3
now, so the version increments. again we
have no way of knowing what the GI
number will be. effectively it will
simply be in a pseudo random number from
a user's point of view as to what that
actual identifier would be. the final
point to make about the accessions
versus the GI'S is a bare accession
without the version, what does that
refer to, that's a really good question because
that accession number currently actually
points to two different versions in
Entrez. if you do a search with the
bare accession you'll get the most
recent version at the time of your
search,
but if you do the search today and six
months later the record is updated to .3
and you do the search again you'll now
get a different sequence back.
alright so again accession.versions
are better to use than accessions because
they point to specific versions, just as
GI's, so that's basically where we are
in terms of accession numbers versus GI
numbers.
why are we changing? a number of reasons.
one of the reasons is we have two
systems, GI numbers and accessions, and
that's not as good as having one
consistent system.
we're trying to move to one system of
identifiers which would be the
accession.version. Accession.versions are more predictable. in other words when they get
updated you know what that's going to be,
you're going to increment the version
suffix. the accession will stay the same,
and they're more human readable.
They have strings in them, the letters at the beginning, that can give you some
information about the type of sequence.
and we have a lot more variety of things
that we can use as accessions. so that's one
other reason to prefer them. they're
better able to handle the large variety
of sequence data that we have coming in
and the amount of that data coming in.
and another reason why we prefer
accession.version at this point in time is, there are
already a large number of sequence
records that do not have gi numbers
assigned to them and never will.
for example wgs contigs, none of those
have gi numbers.
TSA contigs, none of those have gi
numbers, but all of them have accession
.version. so a wgs accession is a long
affair, it has four letters at the
beginning and then a series of numbers
and then a version suffix. tsa
accessions are very similar.
so all of our sequence records
throughout ncbi can be represented
currently with an accession number .
version, but only a subset by GI.
so that's another reason why were moving
towards accession.versions as the
central and unifying identifier.
so what is the time frame of when all
these things are happening?
I've mentioned this a little bit at the
beginning but just to crystallize it.
we had our initial announcement in march.
we had a blog post that came out on our
ncbi insights blog just a few days ago,
and we're doing a webinar now. we'll
continue to do more of these webinars
and more blog posts over the coming
weeks and months as developments occur
with these changes.
we are currently continuing to work on
many of the ramifications of these and
you'll hear about these over time so this
is just the beginning of a series of
things that will be letting the
community know about what will be
happening with these.
In September again gi's
will be disappearing from default
sequence record views, so fasta and flat
files
default views. You will still be able to,
we understand right now, to have a
downloadable option to get a fasta
and flat file view that contains gi
numbers, but they won't be default. and
finally in march of next year, gi's
will not be available at all in sequence
record views.
So what will break right? so what will
these changes - what
consequences will these changes have to a
typical user?
the main issue is to think about any
process that you have that parses GI
numbers from flat files or from fasta.
so if you are using those data records
as a source to get GI numbers out, those
processes will break, because the GI
numbers will simply not be there anymore.
So that's the primary thing
to be concerned about at this point.
And again you have until march to really
fix those processes and update them, but
that's the most important thing to think
about. Things that will not break. If you
have a database that has gi's in it now
those gi's will continue to be
used as retrieval engines for
identifiers for records ncbi. so
any record that has a GI now will
continue to have that gi, will continue
to be retrievable by that GI
indefinitely.
Also the gi's will continue to be in the
xml and ASN.1 presentations of
sequence records.
so if you're using XML or the ASN.1,
nothing will change,
just flat files and fasta. However, and
this is a big however, more and more new
sequences will not be assigned gi's and
it's not going to be predictable which
sequences are going to get gi's and
which ones won't.
so if you only use gi's, the data that you
will be able to access from NCBI will
become more and more obsolete. Or
less and less newer
sequences will actually be able to be
represented in a database that only uses
GI's. So again moving to accession.version is going to be a plus for
keeping up with the most current data. so
our recommendations at this point in
time
again any process that parses GI'S from
flat files or fasta really must be
fixed as soon as possible,
now preferably. so start working on those,
those are the biggest problem. Any
process or database that depends on gi's,
right, for indexing or for retrieval,
should be updated to depend on accession.version instead.
So we're recommending that you switch
those primary keys away from gi's to
accession.versions if you're using
those in some way, and that should be
done as soon as you can possibly do it.
but again the most critical thing is if
you're parsing GI's out of those flat
files or fasta.
Alright, so there's a number of things
that will be happening in addition and
these are not all to the point that we
can tell you specifically about them but
additional webinars, blog post
announcements will cover these topics.
But here are some things that we can
generally expect in the future. In
September or around september we
expect a new parameter to be available
for the E-utilities, these are the
Entrez API's, that will
allow them to accept accession.version
as input and provide accession.version
as outputs. so currently the E-utilities
use GI numbers as their primary keys for
retrieval of sequence data. That
obviously is not going to be a great
idea
moving forward. so we will have an option
to switch the mode in the E-utilities to
use accession.version instead. the
GI version will continue to be the
default and will continue to function
for all sequence records that currently
have GI'S, but to access all of the data
you would need to use this new parameter
to switch to accession.version mode,
if you will, the E-utilities to access data.
EDirect is a fairly recent package that
allows you to use the E-utilities from
the unix command line.
this is described in detail in the E-utilities
documentation, i'm not going to
go into that right now, but that will
also be updated to handle accession.version
input/output and that should be
also in the September time frame.
we understand that in many cases what
these kinds of changes would mean is
that you will need to convert gi's to
accession.version.
We are planning to offer a new
service, again around september, that
would be able to do this in large
batches. So, and by large I mean around a
hundred thousand or more at a time, so if
you do have a large set of gi's and just
want to switch them over to accession.
version we are going to have a service
available for you to do that.
In addition we plan to have some ftp
files that would have the entire set of
gi's that would then associate the
correct accession.version with that GI.
those are fairly large files, they will be
available by ftp. finally in September we
expect that a new version of the blast
binaries will be coming out that will be
using accession.version as opposed
to gi's and we'll have more to say about
blast as events unfold. but those are
some things that we're expecting to
happen in the relatively near future
around September.
So how do you keep abreast of this, how
do you keep in the know,
tell your friends and neighbors about
things that are happening related to
these changes? Please follow our blog
that's NCBI insights, that's
ncbiinsights.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
there's links on our home page there's
links in these
presentation slides, the NCBI News site,
our social media, facebook and
twitter accounts, all of these are again
linked from the NCBI homepage and from the
NCBI news page also. We will be
announcing all of these changes on those
platforms.
so that's a great way of keeping track
and keeping updated on what's happening.
we will be giving additional webinars so
watch out for those. those will be on the
Learn page.
the URL is right there and if you are
interested in the API is or the
E-utilities, it's a great idea to sign up
for utilities announce, and the link is
there to where you can sign up to that
mailing list. it's just a simple email
list where we send out all the detailed
announcements about upcoming changes to
the E-utilities.
And finally if you have questions about
this that we haven't covered today or if
you have questions down the road please
feel free to write to info@ncbi
and we'll certainly be happy to
address those questions.
All right so I'm going to take a break
at this point see if there are questions
that we have to address.
So there's several questions
basically about the E-utilities.
There's a lot of people concerned
about you know how are they going to
work with the new accession.version
formats, so can you address that a little
bit?
What we expect right now and again this
is what I was talking about in terms of
a new parameter that would be coming out
for the E-utilities, is that the parameter
at this point we believe will be called
idtype. So idtype parameter when it's
set to a value of acc,
so you'd add an idtype equals
acc parameter to any E-utility URL, and that
will convert the E-utility into a mode
where it expects to receive accession.
versions and where it will output
accession.version. So a couple of
examples. In esearch for example, esearch typically takes an Entrez query
into like nuccore protein, one of those
databases, and returns to you a list of
gi's right?
We don't want that, we want accession.version, so if you were to add idtype
equals acc, what will happen is you do
the same search using esearch, the
same term, but then what you'll get back
in the XML will be accession.
versions rather than the gi numbers.
Similarly in efetch or esummary you
would be able to provide accession.
versions to the ID parameter. Now in
efetch, just as a trick, you can do that
now.
So efetch does take accession.
versions in the ID parameter now, and it
has for actually a few years.
so you can get that support currently.
Esummary does not.
so esummary only takes gi's currently
so esummary would be changed so that
if you use idtype equals acc, esummary
would be able to take accession.versions
and give you back the doc sums in
xml for those records. And then finally
for eink we would expect that elink
would be able to take the accession.
versions and then if you're linking
into a database, for example linking from
nucleotide protein or from genome to
protein or from PubMed to nuccore, the output
of elink would be in accession.version
rather than GI.
So those are our expectations that's
being worked on right now and we expect
that to be available publicly sometime
in the september time frame.
There are a few other questions, Eric,
that are sort of asking about whether
they're going to have fasta files
available for testing? With the deflines
that are without the GI numbers in
them. And also sort of about like when
will people be expecting fasta files on
the ftp site to change to the new format?
Good questions. So and in terms of the
availability of test files, that is on
our agenda to provide. We expect to be
able to provide some sample
genbank flat files for nucleotide and
protein as well as fasta files in the
near future so keep abreast of the
announcements and we'll announce where
those are coming.
I would point you again, if you would
like, just take a look and that news
article that i showed earlier. It does
have examples of the places in the flat
files and fasta where the gi's are
currently and where they will not be,
alright, in the new in the new data
formats. So even though it's not a full
record it would give you a bit of an
idea about what to expect. But we will be
putting some sample data out so that you
can test with that. In terms of other
presentation formats that are not
directly from Entrez, for example like
ftp files, the genbank releases, RefSeq
releases, the returns that you would get
from the E-utilities, these kinds of
questions. We expect that all of these
data formats
if they're flat files or fasta, will
again not have the gi numbers after
march of 2017.
So that's the drop-dead date. After that
point you will not see GI numbers in any
of the releases of RefSeq, genbank or any of
the other sequence ftp files that we
have nor any of the returns from the
E-utilities or Entrez.
Beginning in September we will begin to
remove the gi's from default presentations.
The first priority with that is going to
be on the web and Entrez presentations
so that's the first thing likely to happen.
I'm not going to be able to give you a
date right now about when those changes
will happen in genbank and RefSeq
releases, except that it will happen
by March of 2017. I think those are the
general topics. There's an interesting
one that I don't know the answer to for
sure.
We've simplified the defline in
another way besides removing the GI
number, this abbreviation for the
database in the fasta defline has gone
away. Now I assume that's largely just to
make things simpler although one person
in the questions pod is concerned about
that because they find it makes it
easier to understand the feature table
format.
Yes thanks for the question. it is true
that the current proposal is to remove
the gb or the ref moniker there that
would let you know what the source
database was. At this point one of the
driving forces for the simplification is
any other third party software
applications and other processes accept
a very simple def line with one
identifier more easily.
that's one of the things that we're
trying to respond to. But I'll take that
under advisement. If there's interest in
having some indication about the
source database, that has come up in some
discussions.
One thing I would say is that in many
cases you can determine from the
accession number format what the source
database is. So the presence of an
underscore in the accession is a dead
ringer that's a RefSeq and that's pretty
much universal rule. Without underscores it's
almost certainly going to be an ISNDC
sequence,
genbank, embl, ddbj. You can also determine
tsa and wgs sequences by the fact that there
are 4 alpha characters in the beginning
of the accession. So there are some rules
that you can use. it may be that we want
to publicize those and tabulate those
little bit more clearly
so that people can see those and use
them to determine sources.
All right, well thank you everyone for your
attention and for attending today and
again please write to us if you have
additional questions in the meantime.
Thank you very much.